and I know I'm a good mother because of
my dedicated last six years of putting
everything aside my career everything
just for her and
you just want a little love Gogol Austin
breaks down in tears after her hubby
iced tea Praises her parenting skills
everything you're smiling
the reality star appeared on Tamron Hall
Tuesday where she got a special shout
out from the Law and Order SVU star you
are the most incredible person I ever
met the nicest person I ever met and the
best mother to should know that anyone
could possibly imagine all right I love
you to death 22 years baby and it gets
better every day and all that had Coco
in tears as a mother you don't hear that
much
you know what you hear that much from
everybody
I have the whole world and I'm
underneath the microscope all the time
and you don't hear what good you do Ice
and Coco share a six-year-old daughter
Chanel she's so much fun I mean I am
like this or my real life doll like to
dress her up and we get to match all day
it's funny I didn't even think I was
gonna be like that parent when I turned
into one you know she's a real fun it's
like the best best thing that happened
to us but Coco has endured a lot of
criticism online for some of her
parenting choices like bathing Chanel in
the kitchen sink and breastfeeding her
past her fifth birthday a choice ice
defended on Twitter last year writing
news flash we feed Chanel food she just
likes to suck mom's boob every now and
then me too that's the great thing then
in May Coco became a trending topic
online after haters called her out for
pushing Chanel in a stroller claiming
she was too old for it but Coco she
clapped back tweeting quote Oh Lord
really people the world loves to
criticize literally everything I do you
don't hear the goodness you just hear a
lot of bad and I know I'm a good mother
because of my dedicated last six years
of putting everything aside my career
everything just for her and
you just want a little love you want a
little disrespect from people
it was really nice sorry well one
thing's for sure Coco has the love and
respect of her man you are the most
incredible person I ever met the nicest
person I ever met and despite any online
chatter the lovebirds have a lot to
celebrate like ice mentioned over two
decades of love and professional wins
too ice was recently named the longest
running male actor in TV history for his
role as detective Finn on Law and Order
SVU the boy saw his father get shot
no child should ever see that it's a
milestone he opened up to E.T about last
month at Heidi klum's Halloween party in
NYC to be on one show continuously for
that long it has never been done are you
having as much fun as you were day one
of the job yeah and then some people
compete and they're saying oh Bart
Simpson got me and then come on somebody
got nothing on ice
[Music]